[Music]
so the background for this is that i've
been going through a lot of my end games
as i do the endgame series
uh trying to find interesting and
instructive end games for my career and
analyzing them
uh so i found some pretty good stuff and
a couple of days ago i stumbled on this
end game that i had which i had
previously analyzed and i'd analyzed it
a bit i knew it was an interesting
little moment
uh but i didn't think much of it but i
decided to re-analyze it with modern
engines and a little bit more deeply and
what i found made my freaking jaw drop
and i don't think i've ever seen more
beautiful ideas arise from a situation
with such few pieces on the board
and in so many different lines each line
that i analyzed contained new
incredible ideas and i think the higher
rated players in the chat might want to
stick around because this is going to be
awesome i'm going to try to walk
everybody through all of the
complications which is not going to be
easy when i'm going to try to do it
slowly and methodically without further
ado i'm going to copy the game over from
chess base and then we will jump in
so this is 2009 to be specific it's uh
february 16 2009 us amateur team west
which is a pretty well known tournament
there's amateur teams
for every part of the of the country and
uh last round my opponent is mark pinto
he's also from the bay area very good
friend uh strong player national master
played for many years i played a nice
positional game it was pretty low key i
outplayed him and uh in this position
white is very very close to winning and
i decided let's finish off the game so
first i played b6
and um
i i mean i think i'm just going to play
b7 and i'm going to win the game
now in this position my opponent
prevented further progress of the pawn
of bishop c8 as it turns out not the
most tenacious defense
now the incredible ideas already start
here because instead of bishop c8 black
had a far more resilient move after
which
white's win would have been put in
serious question
and uh youtube people you can pause the
video try to find this idea this is
really the simplest of all of the ideas
that feature in in this game
the twitch chat so
the moves bishop takes h3
using the pin
against the g-pawn
now this threatens checkmate and the
point is that after king takes h3
black picks up the pawn on e3 with a
fork
the most important thing is that black
then picks up the pawn on b6
and you get this
uh one on three situation this is a
pretty well-known driving white is
unable to make progress here the king is
too vulnerable and white has too few
pawns so this is a slight advantage for
white but essentially a draw
now after bishop h3
uh i spotted that move
and i was very proud
that i that i found a really strong
response white doesn't actually have to
take and you've got this really tricky
move queen back to g3
and the thing to understand about this
move is that it defends against mate it
offers a queen trade and the queen trait
is unthinkable here
although black stops the pawn with
bishop c8 the king is very far advanced
and white can basically play knight d8
at any moment and win pretty easily
uh you could also start with king f4
just getting the king of there is no
hurry but black can't stop knight d and
b7 this is
pretty straightforwardly winning as i
as i uh
analyzed and i saw this line
but i missed the detail
and i missed the detail that black
doesn't actually have to take on g3
either white doesn't have to take on h3
black doesn't have to take on g3
and my opponent could have played this
move queen b2 basically throwing the
bishop to the wolf saying take my bishop
and now you get a two on four so unlike
the one on three this is i think
uh quite a bit more winnable and
according to to stockfish this is
winning for white but it would have
taken
quite a bit of effort and i think
practically speaking black has some
drawing chances here i mean white would
have to finagle you know somehow get the
queen for eventually win the pawn
the knight is very strong here so this
is winning but would have been black's
best defense
uh but my opponent didn't didn't spot
that he played bishop c8
and at this point i decided to finish
the game off and my
approach here was to say all right i
want to trade queens
then i want to go knight d8 or knight a5
followed by b7
i thought okay and i thought i found uh
the best way to force the queen trade i
played the move queen f4 and this is
where the fun
begins because as it turns out queen f4
is a very serious inaccuracy
and we will jump into the rabbit hole
very soon
but first what would have been
a more accurate move a more accurate
move would have been to play the right
idea
the same idea but a slightly different
execution of it
the best move was to play queen g3
so you're posing an unsolvable
uh to black you're posing an unsolvable
ultimatum to black because if black
takes on g3 we've already gone over that
that's completely winning similar to
what we just discussed even without the
pawn on h3 it's completely winning with
the pawn in h3 there's nothing to talk
about
but if black doesn't take on g3 if black
moves over to b2
then you swing the queen over to c7 i
saw that idea and the game is over
you're attacking the bishop you're
attacking f7
and that's it bishop b6 b7 and remember
when the queen is not on f2
this move is no longer effective you can
just take on h3
there is nothing
so queen g3 won on the spot and my
opponent would have resigned
now after queen f4 my opponent resigned
anyway in just a couple of moves he
played queen a2
the only way to preserve uh the f7 pawn
and now i played knight d8 which is not
the most accurate move but perfectly
good enough
and at this point my opponent just he
lost on time but he was resigning at the
same time this is completely winning
because white's gonna go b7 it's a three
on four and that is a very very easy win
b7 cannot be stopped this is also a
threat won the game didn't think much of
it
i thought this was kind of a cool idea
to show students and stuff but then i
started analyzing something far more
interesting
so after b6 bishop c8 queen f4 we had
both made an assumption that we both
considered
very reasonable
what was that assumption
what what assumption are we making when
we play a move like queen f4 what what
are we assuming that we don't even need
to calculate
well
we're assuming that we don't need to
calculate the end game i didn't take
this seriously at all i mean why would
you
it's a three i mean three pawn situation
i'm gonna go knight d8 and b7 and that's
completely winning and that is an easy
win
except the fun begins here because
this end game is one of the most amazing
that i've ever analyzed this position
right here doesn't seem
like anything at all
now
it is true that the b6 pawn is
unstoppable but the amount of
resources that black has in this
position just boggles the mind now
what does black even do how can black
even attempt to defend well in order to
draw the game
black will have to find a way to
eliminate
all three of white's pawns right that's
a simple statement of fact
the only way that you could even try to
eliminate these pawns is with the king
right you're somehow going to have to
get that king which is on the worst
possible spot
all the way around and try to take
white's pawns in the time that white
spends playing knight d8 and b7
so a pretty simple idea arises which is
to play king g7 and to try to get the
king
to f5
the problem is that it just doesn't work
logistically because white goes knight
d8
uh black goes king f6
and
the simplest win for white is not even
to rush with b7 but to first play king
g3 uh securing all of these pawns
and black hits a huge roadblock because
if you go king f5
uh trying to go h4 which is a serious
threat
white has a very astute very clever move
you got to realize that there is no
hurry to play b7 you don't need to rush
with that move
so much so that you can actually go the
other way you could just take on f7
threatening knight d6 and threatening to
come back to d8
and it's not too hard to establish that
after h4
okay king takes h4 king takes f4
white has this move g3 check this is you
know quite technical and this is not the
only win
and after
king f3 there is actually quite a nice
idea again not the only winning idea
but a very very nice winning idea that
white has
again i'd encourage you to pause the
video if you're watching on youtube and
spot the winning sequence for white
because black is threatening to play e3
i'll take another bite in the meantime
now this is a pretty typical idea if
you've studied these types of end games
you will know that the bishop is pretty
easy to overwhelm with trousers and if
you don't know what trousers are then
watch my
um
video on on past puns see that cross
advertisement knight g5 check
get the heck rid of this pawn
go king g5 and black and resign because
you're going to take on g6 and shove
that h pawn up the board there's nothing
that black can do
king f3
now you just need one more accurate move
you don't want to take on g6 because
black takes on g3 you want to go g4
and after king g3 just pushed h4 h5 h6
black can never move the bishop because
of b7 right
not the only one but i thought this was
the nicest one
and
it's not the only one because after
uh king g3 king f5
let me double check this
yeah you actually can go b7 and
basically transpose to that other line
but you can also go b7 instead of king
g3 so really everything is winning there
really everything is everything is
winning there for instance you can go b7
takes takes
and after king f5 you can play the move
g3 and win like this as well because the
devastating threat is 96 check right
there really is nothing to talk about
but
black has one other asset that we have
failed to use what is that asset
well that asset is the past pawn and
maybe we should try to push it so the
idea arises to play e3 and this
threatens e2
and it forces white's king to respond to
the past pawn
now the funny thing is that the move
king g3 actually loses the game
you might notice that the knight is on a
light square and if the king gets to f3
it'll be aligned with the knight black
wins with h4 check
you have to tail the pawn and now black
pins and wins the knight
so we're getting somewhere because e3
now forces the move king g1 for that
reason and now white's king is further
away from
the f-pawn than it would have been in
that other line
and so
some of you might be tempted at this
point to go e2 but remember
you're not trying to promote the pawn
you're not going to promote the pun
you're trying to use the pawn as a decoy
and this actually helps white this gets
the white king closer to the pawn so you
shouldn't play e2
what should you do
well
you know you don't have any time to
waste
you need to get moving you need to get
cracking you got to go king g7
and now you might spot another cool
detail if white now goes king f1
uh this move might seem to win on the
spot you go king f6 white goes king e2
the game is you can't even go king f5
because of a fork or king takes e3 but
all of a sudden that bishop comes in and
gets to a6 with check and black creates
this weird force field
white king is imprisoned
and black walks up to f6 and black is
very close to getting to f5
so
that's
not good for white king f1 is a very bad
move
so
white and this is the critical moment
and i will say as a teaser that white
has only one winning move in this
position
and this move is going to make you fall
off your chair so that's a bit of a hint
but we'll get to this later
what should white try what is the
natural way for white to continue well
the natural way for white to continue is
to play the move knight d8 right and
then play b7 and see what happens
well black can't stop b7 so black has to
continue with king f6
hopefully so far this is making sense
now a lot of you are suggesting
you're you guys are suggesting moves for
now i don't want you to focus on that
moment we'll get to that
first i want us to analyze it because
this is where the beauty is contained
in order to understand the winning move
we have to understand why this doesn't
win
so
let's start by going down the most
straightforward line and that is b7
here the fun begins um i mean the fun
has already begun the fun continues i
should say black has to sack
and now black has to advance the king to
f5
now we get a pretty interesting
situation here
we get a pretty interesting situation
here
because
if white goes g3
a lot of you
might be very very tempted to play
h4
h4 is like the instinct reaction but h4
actually loses to 96 check you can trust
me on that and we won't go down this
line the reason we won't go down that
this line is because king e4 is a pretty
elementary draw and white actually has
to be careful here because the king is
coming to f3 and black is just taking
everything the white has to be very
cautious white has to go king up to g2
and again now you use this pawn as a
decoy you go e2 then you go e1 you force
the king back and then you just start
taking everything you take all of
white's pawns this is a draw and this
should make sense too
so the move
g3 is is not tenacious at all
but white doesn't actually have to
preserve the f pawn as long as white
keeps one of these pawns alive it should
be able to win
okay so the idea arises
let's go knight d6 check and let's grab
the f7 pawn while we
still can
while we still can
all right now again you might look at
this for a second say wait a minute well
what if black now tries to use the pawn
as the decoy and goes the e2 and then e1
queen
well does that work well no it doesn't
because after king g3 white is in time
to go king f1 and black and resign
so again rather than
you know making the counterproductive
movie too you want to first get your
king up to g3
threatening to promote the pawn with e2
now can white stop the pawn
well yes of course so i can stop the
pawn why can stop the pawn with the
knight from
the f3 or d3 square let's
uh assume that the knight goes to f3 it
doesn't actually matter knight e5 e2
and knight f3 and we get this position
okay
so black's goal is very clear black
needs to find a way to trade both of
these pawns the knight is tied down to
the pawn but black's moves are also
limited you get a mutual zugzwang
situation here
because if you move your king away then
you can resign white's king gets out
takes the pawn and
black's resources are extinguished
so
black has to push pawns g5 is the only
move
white's strategy is going to be to try
to wait it out with his knight why it's
going to go back to e1 only move
and this is
incredible moment number one
black has only one drawing move your
only two feasible moves are g4 and h4
again you can't move the king away
that's ridiculous
which move draws and which move loses
next moment at which i'll pause the
video for the youtubers
take your time i'll give you a couple of
moments think about this
this isn't the most beautiful moment by
a long shot but it's quite nice
okay
so the move believe it or not
is it h where is it g4 to me the most
natural moves to play g4 because this
seems to force a train
a lot of you
if i understand your logic right
might be considering okay so white has
to take
black takes with the king and in the
time that white takes to win the pawn
black advances the h pawn h4
now king takes e2 and h3
and this is a draw
but the amazing thing is that after g4
as some of you indicated white can play
the move h4
h4
and this wins the game for white
because after king takes h4 all that
white needs is one pawn and black is
unable to trade that pawn after what
black goes h4
white goes knight d3
and white's gonna push black's king off
of the ledge because h3 is always met
with g3 and this is a theoretically
winning end game
you can dig around on your own but you
should trust me on this this is winning
white stops the pawn with the knight and
uses the king to shoulder the the
opposing king you get a situation like
this
where king e5 walks into a check while
king g5 allows white to shoulder the
king and win the g-pawn
so h4 sacking one of the pawns wins the
game and so black has to start with h4
but that's not the end of it because
after knight d3 black plays g4
white has to take
black recaptures
and here
white can try so if king f2
then it's easy black plays h3 and makes
a draw immediately
if white goes king h2 black now has to
go the other way black goes king f5
runs the king to e4
attacks the knight
runs it to e3 and draws by a single
tempo after king f2 if white's king
could have come back to h3 it would have
been a win white would have gone knight
c2 but now the knight can't move without
giving up the pawn so it's a draw
the other winning attempt that white has
is to go knight f3 instead how does this
change the scenario
well black plays g4
white has to take black takes
now king h2 is not interesting anymore
because black can use the overloaded
nature of the spawn to play h3 right
make a draw
but why can't try striking f2 and we
have yet another incredible moment
vast majority of you probably thinking
h3 draw
but h3 loses
white has this move knight h2 check
and
okay well you have to keep contact with
the pawn but after king h4
white shoves the king away with g3
forcing the king back
takes on e2 and wins the game
so hopefully that line made sense and
stop me if i'm from going too fast so
once again h3 knight h2 check and white
creates another one of these force
fields in winds e2
so black has a ridiculous idea what
should black do in this position
and we're not even at the at the nicest
part yet so this will be a long one
what black needs to do here is use the
pawn as a decoy and promote white can
take this with either the knight or the
king
but
against both moves h3 draws if the king
takes
h3 draws because knight h2 loses its
effectiveness black's king now has g3
whereas with the viking on f2
you know black's king didn't have g3
if white takes with the knight then
after h3 in order to avoid the trade
white should play g3 and now you use the
other pawn as a decoy you go h2
white has to stop it h1 queen and you
draw with king takes g3
and that's how you do it that's how you
draw pretty simple
e1 queen in this position forcing white
to take with one of the pieces and then
h3
just
incredible
so h4 only drawing move here
let's go all the way back because we're
not done with this line
what we just discussed
is
the move
knight d8 king f6 and
b7
that's the line we discussed
but white has another move
white has another move you might say
well wait a second
black wants to go king f5
what if i
allow the trait of one pair of pawns but
what if i stop him how can you stop
black from coming to f5 well you can say
i understand that the bishop is tied
down to the b7 square and you can use
that to play the move g4 creating
another force field h takes g4 h takes
g4
and now the logic is very simple you're
going to play b7 and then you're going
to casually amble your king up to e2
now to me
the
obvious and natural move that you kind
of your hand wants to play this move is
is g5 you want to create a pathway for
the king to f4 right and if white takes
well then white gets rid of all of his
pawns so white has to play f5
and king e5 might seem to draw the game
you might say well why does force to
play b7
you know and then black takes it and
black just goes king f4 and just takes
all the pawns right
except white is not forced to play b7
and if you were paying attention earlier
uh there was an important point about
not rushing with b7 you can just go back
and take on f7
and then you can return to d6 and you've
got trousers of your own epon is safely
restrained by the king f6 is coming next
and
you know the pawns are are unstoppable
black spawns are clearly much slower so
that doesn't work this position is
losing for black because after white
plays f5 the king is stuck to the f7
pawn
so g5 doesn't work
e2 is counterproductive due to king f2
you have to take the long way around
right you can't go this way
you got to go through the back door so
you have to go back to e7 that's the
only move
well white plays b7 you're forcing his
hand um
sean pinto was suggesting bishop basic
but bishop a6
white can amble up to g2 and then
prepare to go to f3 that's that's the
issue
right you're you're white doesn't have
to rush with b7 as long as you haven't
played kingston so you have to force
white's hand you have to force white to
go b7
and then you get this situation after
bishop b7 knight b7
and this is
the most incredible part of the endgame
this is what made my jaw drop this
sequence
okay well
the only feasible approach seems to be
to now go king e6 and then try to get
this king around to d5 and e4
but there's this theme in this end game
where white basically uses the weakness
of the f7 pawn to keep tying black's
king down not allowing it to get to d5
so if you were to bring your king up to
g2
then it would be a draw and it would be
a draw using the same method that we've
encountered again and again at the right
moment using the e pawn as a decoy you
go e2 you force it to take and white
can't defend both of these pawns
but as many of you are suggesting
you can now go knight d8 check
posing an unstoppable and irresolvable
ultimatum
if black still goes king d5
if black still goes king d5 and says i
don't care about the f-pawn well white's
going to care about the f1 because now
you can use what you learned in the pawn
breakthrough video
this is uh the easy breakthrough this is
the simplest type of breakthrough you go
f5
you force black to take you go g5 and
black is blocked by his own pawns
um and and cannot
cannot stop the pawn white wins
king d5
now the the simplest win is actually
knight d8 stopping the king from getting
to e6
king d6 g6 beautiful sequence look at
how the knight stops the king from
coming to f7
and this is really nice too
but the long and short of it is that
black cannot go forward
black has to go back to e7
and it may seem
that black actually draws the game
because white's knight is attacked and
you get a situation you get a standoff
where white's knight goes back black's
king goes back
right
but now white has another incredible
resource remember that black has only
one pawn for the night so what move is
now on the table
and white has a secondary win but this
in my opinion is the nicest and and
cleanest
it's it's knight takes f7
king takes f7 and now you walk over and
you take e3 just in the nick of time and
you get a theoretically winning end game
for example king e6 king e2
there's nothing to talk about here king
f6 if black just does nothing
uh white's going to shoulder black's
king i mean the classical method king f6
king d5
and if the king goes the other way then
you can uh
you can't play a five yet actually f5
king e7 is a draw
a well-known trap so i
caught myself but king d4 is the win and
again you you shoulder black scene
regardless like this
um so knight f7 is the is the cleanest
one
and that um
excludes the move king e6 which which
means the black is lost
but wait a second black is not lost this
is still a draw
now you might say okay well if i can't
go king e6 let me try the longer round
let me try like this
but
this doesn't even come close this is
even worse because white goes 98 here
and you've lost the tempo in comparison
to the other line
okay so is there anything else that
black can try well now you might say
well what if i push one of these pawns
right if you play g5 we've already been
through this we know this is lost this
is the same
as
as if
black had played g5 here and we've
already been over this this isn't even
close
this isn't even close it's not kino king
f6
is not it
so g5 loses
but you can play f5
well how does this help right it seems
that after g5 white wins
but remember what was the problem with
king e6 the problem was that the f pawn
was saddling you forcing you to go back
without the f pawn sitting on f7 you can
safely go forward and knight d8 check
loses its effectiveness because the king
can go to d5
and after king f1 white is not in time
to make it to e3 black beats him to the
punch and goes king e4 takes both of
white's pawns and draws
does that make sense
so g5 allows black to draw with king e6
but white doesn't have to play g5 g5
loses the tempo white can take on f5
and again this looks like a totally
winning position after gf white just
goes king f1 and wins the pawn and this
time white is in time to get to e3
and this is the jaw dropping sequence
that i was hyping up all video long
because after g takes f5
it turns out that g takes f5 is not
forced let's flip the board for a second
adjust yourself to this position for
just a moment
and see if you can find the incredible
drawing sequence
black to play
and another short pause
solid pause
it is king f6
it is king f6
and here's the thing
you're keeping the pathway open at the
cost of a pawn if white takes
then black takes you're threatening king
f5 you're threatening to win the pawn
if white plays king g2
you can basically drive the the pawn all
the way to e1 again using it as a decoy
and then playing king f5
okay
but here's the thing white can go knight
d6 and create another force field
stopping the king from coming to f5 but
this time you take the longer route you
go king f6 king f1 king e6 attack the
knight force it back and then go king f5
and win upon then i can't move anywhere
where it will be capable of defending
the sponges mathematically
just mathematically right king will go
to f5 and f4 and hopefully that makes
sense and you might say wait a minute i
can give up the knight and get a winning
pawn in game this is not winning this is
a draw because the pawn is in front of
the king
this is an easy draw it doesn't matter
who has the opposition when the pawn is
on the same level as the king opposition
doesn't matter it's a theoretical draw
but it's still not over because
black wasn't forced to take on f5
and now you might say well i'm not
forced to take on g6 either
and the approach to trying trying to win
this game for white is to say i want to
force black to play g takes f5 to block
the access to the f4 pawn how can white
try to engineer that
so the move that white is trying to
prevent here is king takes f5 that is
the threat
so you use your knight to prevent that
you go knight d6
and
this seems forced
now white wins elementarily by playing
knight c4 and then winning the e3 pawn
and as many of you are pointing out this
move
literally made me i don't know i was
just i was like i have to make a video
about this and i saw this move
after 96 black plays g6 g5 and this is
the drawing move
this is the trying move nobody takes any
of the pawns
now what the heck is the logic behind
this again you're trying to get to the
important part you're using your last
resource to eliminate the f4 pawn
white has to take if fight doesn't take
then you take on f4 and you create
connected passers white has to take and
now you should see how the drawing
mechanism works the knight is tied down
to the pawn
the king keeps contact with the pawn and
maneuvers its way to e5 dislodging the
knife from d6 white's king is clearly
unable to do everything in time
you go up to e5
and you draw the game why does nothing
better than to take on e3 you take d6
and again it might seem winning it might
seem like white gets here in time but he
doesn't king e7 and in the nick of time
black makes it to f7
in the nick of time black makes it to f7
so let's go over that sequence again
the craziness starts here first you have
to find this move f5 getting
rid of your weakness on f7
white takes on f5 you don't take back
you go king f6 now white doesn't take on
g6 white tries knight d6 and rather than
taking on f5 you move past it going
after the important pawn the f4 pawn
then you use your king to win the last
remaining pawn on f5
and so all of that means all of that
means
that the move knight d8 leads to a draw
now we won't spend an equivalent amount
of time on the winning move but there is
a winning move that i admit i did not
find at all the engine found it
and the idea behind the winning move is
that you need to use the same logic that
black used in playing f5
what was that logic so let's
you know roll the cameras again so it's
blah blah blah sorry not here
g4 takes takes king e7
b7
what was the logic behind going a five
well it was to get rid of your biggest
weakness
well what is white's biggest weakness
if we now rewind all the way back to
here well white's biggest weakness is
also the f4 pawn
and what move tries to get rid of it for
better or for worse we flip the board
one more time
the incredible move is f4 f5 the only
winning move you can check with the
engine i checked at a very high depth
i'm 99 sure that this conclusion is
correct
the move f5 wins the game
how does it work
well first of all bishop f5 b7
if black takes with a pawn then you have
ruined black's pawn structure and the
simplest win is to go 97
got to move the bishop pick up f5 then
you move to d6 and go b7 and the issue
is that black's pawn structure is
disjointed which means that none of the
same techniques that worked with the
conjoined pawns work here you can go
down the same exact line
we had this exact position with the pawn
on g6 now it's winning for white knight
c5
and you're also a tempo behind
you're also a tempo behind king g3
knight d3 but it doesn't even matter e2
knight e1 same exact position remember
there you had h4 here the pawns are
disjoint
so white just waits it out
here
knight e1
h4 just knight f3 zhuxwan
it's not stalemate black promotes
then black is forced to play f3 and in
doing so opens up a pathway for the king
to f4
so white just waits him out with 91 and
knight f3 another incredible idea if
black's king moves away remember white
goes king f2
so the disjointed pawns win the game for
white
now you could say well wait a minute i
can just ignore right i can play king f6
but this time eliminating your weakness
on f4 allows this end game to be a win
king e5 b7 and this time we have the
same position as before but white is up
a tempo we had this position with the
black gang sitting on g3 and here white
wins by going knight c5
and if the king reaches g3
this is where the tempo comes in
knight d3 e2 transposes to the old line
but what very clever maneuver does white
have to force the king out of g3 where
should white's knight actually go here
no not king f1 not king f1 because of e2
check don't forget about this idea using
the pawn as a decoy
no no no 94 check is correct you force
the king back
and you migrate to c3
and the whole point of this is that you
finally go back to e2 and then you smoke
the king out with king h2
and a fitting end would be g5 g3
checkmate because what haven't we seen
in the same game we haven't seen a
checkmate yet there it is
there it is
and if king g5 then obviously king g3
and the rest is is history just take
over you just take the pawn
so
if we compare these two positions right
all the way back if we play
knight d8
um king f6 b7 we have to waste the tempo
to then go after the f-pawn
that is what we save time on
that is what we save time on
so this position
you have to go back to d6 and then to f7
but with the f pawn already disposed of
with the f1 already disposed of
we don't have to waste time
to go back around to d and f7 we can go
straight for the promised land
that's the bottom line king f4 you go
knight c5 and black has to choose his
poison either e2 king f2 we know this is
winning or king g3 94 knight c3 and 92
and finally
you might say well what about g5 we've
already gone over this we know this is
winning this is a direct transposition
to uh a line that we already discussed
after king d8 knight d8
king e5 thank you over the five subs
king e5 knight takes f7 check and this
is winning for white
and this concludes the end game analysis
with f5
in this position being the only winning
move after king g1 kg7 and knight d8
containing all of those brilliant ideas
did you have any enough time during the
game to calculate anything no that's the
point i'm trying to make not only i did
have enough time to calculate this but
it didn't even occur to me that queen
takes f4 was possible much less the
abundance of these ideas in this end
game and i think this is why
i'm so passionate about fighting this
idea that end games are boring like this
is what end games are all about
are they ridiculously complicated yes
but is it wicked fun to look at this
stuff also yes and i think part of the
the beauty of it comes from the fact
that there are there is so little
material left so if you're trying to win
it's a battle of desperation or one side
tries to cling to their last remaining
pawn
and the other side uses every resource
at their disposal to
force the opponent to get rid of it
that's where these incredible tactical
ideas come from
there would be no way that i would see i
maybe i would find f5 if i took 15-20
minutes
i doubt it though i think i would
probably have automatically played
knight d8 thank you for eye level for
the 2000 but that's where i'm going to
conclude the youtube video so i hope
you guys enjoyed this little foray into
this ridiculous end game that remained
behind the scenes and we'll remain
behind the scenes forever
but uh you can expect more
uh you can expect a regular pawn engine
video as my next uh entry into the
endgame series so thanks for watching
hope you
survived and enjoyed
okay now i'm back to the twitch stream i
just had to do that because
i'm gonna put this on youtube
and uh yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
thank you drujo for the five subs
appreciate it
um
you know i hope that made
some degree of sense like my
explanations i i do go pretty fast in
these cases but
every individual line i think is pretty
easy to understand
but it's the conjunction of them that
makes us insane
so
teach your voice is off regular voices
on that's right
glad you enjoyed it thank you for the
support everybody and this will be up on
youtube pretty soon
see you guys later thanks again bye
[Music]